I would say it's about 810 years it was
really painful and I think when lose you
to love me came out and the reaction it
got I definitely knew it was a special
song I didn't know that it was going to
become so first number one people
responded to in such a huge way I think
when that happened I had a moment where
I said I completely get it
Selena Gomez's album rare is out now and
first of all it's great
koulos into it but also she's getting a
really candid about the process and
about her life we've got all of the
clips you need to see here we go like it
was easy I've obviously have gone
through some stuff and I had moments of
being super inspired and throughout the
years I would have this patch of time
where I would feel like I needed to just
say all the nasty things and all the sad
things that I needed to get out and then
I wouldn't do them I wouldn't do any
more than that and I'm really glad that
I didn't rush this process Selina
opening up about the very personal
process of making rare at her album
release party a fun fact she co-wrote
every single song including the title
track which we just got a music video
for it
[Music]
it's the song that says I know that I
don't have it all but I do know that I
deserve something special and that song
is exactly how I feel I won't tolerate
being treated any other way girl preach
another song that fans are loving is
vulnerable I'll stay for neural there
comes a point where forgiveness is
necessary but it's also something that
you need to release and this song is
called vulnerable because it's like no
matter how much you know anyone puts me
down it's I'm still gonna stay the same
so I'm still gonna cry I don't you know
random things I'm very emotional as what
I'm trying to say so this is one of my
favorites I think that for me I'm really
big on vulnerability I think people are
really scared to be honest with
themselves and strength has looked upon
us
oh I'm strong I don't need anything I
can't hate I can handle everything and
that's just not the truth
Selina also opened up about several
other tracks and a common theme that we
noticed she's totally moved on from the
past you can have all of these feelings
but now I'm ready to kind of just let
loose and I've got mice like it's so
cheesy but I've got my step back there's
so many places I could go you know
there's so many things I could do not
being held down by some good she also
talked to Apple musics Zane Lowe about
her personal life because people can't
seem to stop asking her about this but
she actually had a super honest answer
about what it is like dating in the
public eye everyone dates everyone and
so it always seems to be within a little
bubble and and it's because it's safe
right it's you know you're you're
wanting someone to understand what
you're going through but the problem
with that is that you end up whether you
admit it or not you're having a
relationship for the people
like you just need to decide within our
world it fits for yours it for show
there's a lot to unpack here but rare is
so good let us know what your favorite
track is and for all the latest on
Celina make sure that you stick with all
things ET until next time I'm Katie
crafts and bye for now
[Music]